benvenuti solida storia
oggi i nuovissimi scherzi a vincere al
fidanzato di skater nello stesso video
vi ho detto che il video mette raggiunto
i 15 mila mi chiesi avremmo fatto un
altro episodio con gli scherzi o scritti
sere ascheri stringere il video ha
superati quindi mi piace quindi lasciato
un bel mi piace anche su questo video è
anche questo video super e 15 mila mi
piace se farà un uomo scherzi o per
impedire skater come sempre la b del
video ci potrete dire qual è stato il
vostro scherzo preferito e questa è la
fine o almeno dovrebbe essere la fine
del gioco scheri stranger sono appena
usciti molinelli nuovi scherzi però
questa è proprio la fine vediamo come
finirà prendete i pop corn le fiji e
comodi se non mi seguite ancora si
integra mandati a seguirmi e iniziamo
subito pratiche vi prima scherzo vai
vediamo che succede
poker.it speciale di pasta un ragno
gigante
non è cominciato con il primo direi
assicuriamoci che il vicino riceva una
visita spavento ma mi ha spaventato
dalla reazione di registi l'invasore
fini ha paura dei ragni vento giacché
gli fare un bello scherzetto una pinza
un filo riprendendo tutte queste cose è
visto che lui mi sembra che abbia paura
dei ragni quindi perché non gli facciamo
uno scherzo angelo costruiamo noi un
taglio così lo spaventeremo atteggiarmi
stanno scendendo
lo sapevo sorpreso nasconderci guarda
una pianta che sembra proprio un ragno
andiamo queste foglie e poi le coloriamo
[Musica]
sembra uno dei tentacoli di ragno
questo scherzo stiamo facendo un po art
attack perdono il musicista già
rincorrendo qui nella stanza dell'orso
vi ricordate lo scherzo dell'orso se non
avete visto andati a vederlo qui c'è un
cappello che noi andiamo a prendere un
improvviso dovremo stare molto attenti
quindi ora abbiamo tutti gli oggetti si
cela manca solo uno ea troviamo proprio
col vicino guarda
ma ecco qual è la colla e l'immancabile
clan
adesso andiamo a preparare lo scherzetto
qui nel suo studio vi ricordate che
all'inizio lui stava spolverando qui ed
è uscito il ragno quindi adesso che cosa
facciamo gli mettiamo un ragno né
gigante il fondo
iniziamo col cappello i tentacoli il
filo di ferro berlino il tutto bella
cover
guardate lo so ora però dobbiamo
scappare perché ho paura che lui ti
arrivando qui vi volevo dire che qui ho
scoperto un passaggio segreto
bisogna aprire qua
voglio far vedere che cosa c'è e cosa
ottima quindi c'è praticamente una spesa
di cantina con tutte le sue cose buttate
all'interno tra l'altro una lavatrice
pazzo distruggere forse meglio uscire
perché qui non siamo abbastanza al
sicuro quando c'è la porta aperta ma
andrei dire ancora lì
sì sì questo molto lo finale brighi
aquino ha detto resca promesso che
avremmo la porta in via questa volta che
ci può prendere uno studio ma la sua
anima ha lasciato il corpo prossimo
scherzi voto scherzo se la nostra
amatissima bis
vediamo questa stessa si chiama
impostore contro un tuo store è forse
uno prese ispirazione da among us file
uno scherzo del primo aprile epico al
vicino facendo in modo che lui sempre un
cattivo di fronte i suoi scritti quindi
pesce d'aprile
evitiamo stanno facendo una chiamata o
sei dischi
[Musica]
quello che si riprenderà ha fatto una
videochiamata con tutti gli altri e ha
detto che sta organizzando una festa
alle varie per cacciarci quindi sta
organizzando questa festa in maschera in
cui invitato spiriti cercherò per i due
ladri è il gorilla e ha detto che si
sono rotti le scatole di questi bambini
che arriva a casa penso che si riferisca
a noi attenzione perché c'era anche un
personaggio misterioso nella chiamata
non so se hai notato serafini c'era una
schermata in cui di solito sono cioè
c'era un futuro però era di spalle della
tutto nero non si vedeva
quindi scopriremo col tipo di muro con
wow vogliono cercare di spaventarci
questo la festa in maschera e in cui si
travestiranno da mostri immagino quindi
vogliono spaventarsi e fare in modo che
non torniamo più in casa loro a parte
gli scherzi ma secondo me non ci
riusciranno
nel frattempo che testa ma siamo già
venti minuti mai scappato bisogna sempre
dietro casco stanca maisky ristretta il
rito si non basta adesso gli dirò questo
addosso
[Musica]
no non basta quindi l'obiettivo è
rovinare il loro segreto da me
intenzione di rovinare la loro pezzo
segreta cercando vista sto cercando un
po di cosette perché praticamente vedete
lui qui ha preparato dei regali che
guidano detenzione non mi faccio prete i
regali dobbiamo trovare qualcosa da
mettere all'interno di quei fatti per
rovinarmi quindi vuoi sostituire i
regali con quel con qualcos'altro
ma il geniale maestro ad esempio proprio
per scheri dice però qui abbiamo anche
qualcos'altro guardate c'è scritto per
per spray al peperoncino e quindi la
lezione per chi è el'adozione peschieri
diceva perché i sessi e adesso sembra
tanto cattivo come er un regalo adesso
per capire del perché qui dove ci sono i
pacchi chiudiamo la porta
hai già preso tutto quello che serve
quindi più o meno più bello
regali perché una parte di tiziano uno
per ieri romero e poi c'era l'apertura
categoria e la persona misteriosa adesso
cominciamo con questi ok allora
innanzitutto apriamo il pacco ed in
questa sede non si riesce a vedere solo
una sera qui possiamo solo mettere lo
spray al peperoncino che è iniqua
mettiamo lo straniero era troppo bello
vederli aprire queste le casa
noi mettiamo sopra la cosa lo copriamo
così lui la carta regalo fatto libero lo
dobbiamo nascondere bene quindi qui
dietro c'è lo scotch
sì perché sono senatore scherzo si trova
ad accorgersi detto quindi questo
apparato questo e pescherie robert e
adesso indiani spirits fair dove al
piano di sopra proceduto io ho trovato
l'ho trovato un ragazzo di luglio tra lo
porta prima che sarà pagamento ok almeno
siamo come queste eccolo qua allora
dobbiamo trovare gli altri attrezzi qui
allora abbiamo bisogno del taglierino e
per aprire il regalo quindi taglierino
mettiamo la lozione
[Musica]
effetto l'abbiamo sostituita
adesso ci manca solo lo scotch per
chiudere bene il banco allora lo scotch
vi diamo tre un area regione prende no
no no forse lo troviamo qui dobbiamo
giusto bravissimo
ok preso lo scorso luglio nel piano di
questi tre le camere di sicurezza dei
talent perfetto l'abbiamo chiuso per me
scappiamo stato vediamo il bustone
ma il fratello gemello di ieri stranger
a un prete così bello che era
l'impostore vietano è quello che ha
mostrato all'inizio che era di spalle
forse era proprio lui che ci sono due
schieri stretto da non riusciamo a
scappare da uno è dovuto scappare da ad
un credo che questo sia bob il fratello
di scary stranger non ne sono sicuro
però credo sia bob capitoli della che
francis era vestito da impostore di
hammond
esatto per ora scherzerà divertenti 1
perchè magari deezer diventava pelate
loro
per la sala della barba sembra che
faremo qualcosa di di gastronomia camuna
col fuoco mi dice il pomeriggio del
vicino sta per diventare molto come si
dice acceso acceso un gioco di parole ha
detto shah joy che ha bruciato un soffio
allora l'obiettivo è dobbiamo riuscire a
far impazzire il vicino sicuramente a
che fare col fuoco quindi vediamo che
cosa abbiamo a disposizione una pinza un
tubo
vediamo un po la pena senza ovviamente
15 kg mentre una fuga tutta casa
rimuoviamo il tappo della benzina della
macchina poi mettiamo il tubo la panica
via da lì a essere però se ci pensi
seguire bruciamo la casa skate stranger
lui andrà a vivere con scarichi share e
poi fare gli scherzi al che registro
sarà ancora più difficile perché se loro
non assieme sarà impossibile ok allora
adesso andiamo in cucina le stanno
cucinando
basta basta basta vogliamo affatto
tranquilli stranamente ma non abbiamo
fatto in tempo a 3 per i fiammiferi ci
sono caduti dalle tasche forse dalla
moto vi piacciono i miei nuovi orecchini
guardate sono dei distributori di gomme
da masticare in miniature parere lui è
arrabbiatissimo quindi sa che dobbiamo
sbrigarci ci ho già preso tutto visto
che lui stava mettendo il quadro qui li
tagliamo le gambe così cade ma poi ci
mettiamo dell'odio così male se questo
piatto è cattivissimo me come ultimo
aperto dove essere il più cattivo di
tutti
lui il codino aspettiamo che salverà
perché dobbiamo prendere ancora un
ultimo oggetto allora ci serve ancora
un'ultima cosa che troviamo qui nel
capanno degli attrezzi malori per bene
questo ti ricapita vicinissimo con il
gatto dibattimentale ricordate beh per
il camino giustamente si serve la lena
ultimo la swan
qui è scivolato perché hai tagliato le
gambe tesa scoglio però siccome non hai
messo la legna il fuoco nel camino il
fuoco era spesso filmato è andato vicino
ok ho ricominciato è tutto da cavi o già
adesso la legna nel camino
adesso la benzina di protesta che è
fuori è fuori come impatto sentirsi
cantiamo il tavolino
momento stavamo facendo uno scherzo
abbiamo messo l'olio da cucina di
malasanità sono i fiammiferi coi è
perfetto
speriamo che non arrivi tu da gioco non
sappiamo se continueranno dal giornale
forse proprio perché è stato introdotto
bob il fratello che nessuno conosce
anello che nessuno conosceva infatti sia
il fratello gemello di francis kéré ci
sarà un nuovo gioco io lo spero davvero
anche perché come regina scritti se ora
che sa che presto un gemello cosa ne
pensate secondo voi continueranno con
scheri stranger nuovi livelli oppure è
finito per tutto e ci sarà un nuovo
gioco scriverlo sono gli aumenti secondo
voi francis continuerà ad apparire in
skate it oppure non si starà più oggi
faranno tutti e due
queste scheri di cell impazzirà rosa
proprio a chi trattare male congiuntura
che vede sin i commenti guarda ne
pensate e ora cliccate su una di queste
quattro che salirono per vedere i nostri
altri video il caso su quella che
preferite
buona visione ciao